Hello and welcome. It's August 16,
2023. We're in the collective behavior
discussion section of the active
inference for the Social sciences course
in 2023. So perhaps let us
all go around and give an
opening in introduction and or
reflection and see who
joins and what happens from there. But
just so that everybody has said hello.
Hi, everyone. I'm Brun 09:00
P.m. In South Africa, and, yeah,
just excited to be and see what happens.
Hi, I'm Andrew. I'm a graduate student
in Indiana,
and I guess my field
of interest now is knowledge management.
And I think that figuring out how we
collectively learn and can share
information is a really interesting
topic, and I'd like to see how this
would apply.
Hi, I'm Gina, and I'm from Guatemala,
but I'm living in Spain, studying and
doing experiments related to this topic
and trying to learn a little bit of the
theory that's behind it so we can
advance better. I'm excited.
Hello. My name is Sasha. I'm calling in
from California. I'm also a graduate
student. Yeah, just really enjoyed the
spirited presentation last week.
I'm looking forward to a discussion.
All right, well, how about anyone
can give a first reflection
on collective behavior?
What was their thought or context
before, and where are they at as we kind
of begin? Yeah, Regina.
Okay, so I just want to make sure that I
understand because I took, like, two big
lessons from your lesson, right?
And the first one is that this
famous model of active inference that
has the agent and the environment
and the Markov blanket in the middle,
right? And just interacts with
everything. Right. So I think what I got
from what you discuss, maybe I didn't
have a good definition of an agent, but
first, that you can have that agent not
be just an individual, but also your
definition of an individual changes
depending on what you want to study in
the behavior. Right. So an agent can be
an ant, it can be an ecosystem,
it can be an eye looking at something,
or it can be as a society, for example.
And I think that's a big take for me
because it changes a lot the concept of
how to study things and use active
imprints just by changing how big the
agent can be. So I don't know if I got
that right. So first, that
clarification.
So what is an agent?
Yeah, so I don't know if there's, like,
a formal definition of an agent in
active inference. Right. But if
we want to study whatever we want,
because I'm about study, because I have
to do that's, like, my goal, whatever
I'm doing. So I want to study whatever
I have to choose what's going to be my
agent and the environment it has. So
choosing the agent, you can do it to
create a model or to make an experiment,
whatever. But the
choice you make, it will depend on what
you understand as an individual or as an
agent? I think so. Right.
Awesome. Anyone have a thought on that?
If I continue with something, just to
add something else, and this will be my
mind. And then I'm thinking,
is that also a big
problem that we have or I think I have,
is that since I am part
of the environment,
you know, the perspective of whoever is
studying whatever it is, it's also going
to be an effect in it. So maybe
scientists already decided, but I don't
know that we can never have an objective
way of studying something if you're
part of the environment of the agent.
So, I don't know, we already forgot it
or we already decided that's it we
cannot have objective observations of
behavior in general. But you always
think about the agent environment and
you studying it as something else, but
something else is also affecting it. So
I see that as a problem or maybe
something that has to be said, like we
are not objective because we're part of
what it's affecting our agents in the
behavior collectively too. So those are
the thoughts I have to share.
Regina, I'm also new to all of this. So
my preliminary understanding of what is
an agent is anything that has
any good reason to self evidence
and to itself or to survive
that doesn't want to dissipate, that
might delineate the boundary of what an
agent is. That then sets up the
boundaries with which it will,
as you describe, start interacting with
the world, with the environment. So if
something, as I understand it, if
something has a reason to go on being to
survive,
then it is an agent in the world.
Okay, but that agent could be anything,
right? Is that what you're saying?
Right? Like, if he wants to survive,
can be an ant surviving individually or
a cell or a a good that's
like a good definition.
Okay. Yeah.
Sasha. Great points.
Regina, so much to say. There something
that I have experience with as a
researcher in biology is deciding the
kind of the statistics or
sampling approach to use, whether we're
taking one cell from one individual
or we're taking many cells from many
individuals, and how to do the
statistics and kind of sampling approach
on that. That is an evergreen question
that we're always reevaluating to see
how to think about the independencies
within biological systems.
And then another thing that you
mentioned was about the individual being
part of the ecosystem. And that makes me
think a lot about complexity science and
something that is addressed there in
thinking about the interplay of the
scientists and what they're studying.
Yeah, thank you for those points.
Sasha. Can sorry, I'm not raising my
hand, I'm just unmuting it. That's okay.
Can you say a bit more about what you
mean by complexity science?
Maybe muted? Oh, can't speak
at the moment.
Yeah. Complexity science has looked
at agent based modeling as a fundamental
tool. John Holland signals and
boundaries, focusing on what from an
active inference side, we might say, as
like message passing or communication
for the messages and then boundaries
with the whole discussion around
the boundaries in the world. Map
territory, map territory fallacy.
Map territory fallacy. Fallacy.
Doing iterative modeling. Sasha brought
up limited experimental resources in
the scientific setting, and that's kind
of analogous to the limited energy
budget or attentional budget ultimately,
or just decision making budget of the
kinds of active entities that make
sense to model the ones that kind of
have those characteristics.
This is really the question of what
makes something first principles or what
are the first principles? One aspect
of it, as brought up is the censoring
of the persistence. So from the outside,
that's kind of like an empiricist's view
of persistence, like, is it measurable?
But not saying that something is
necessarily that which is the
statistical tool, and then the sort of
like inside out implementation type.
But there's a lot more to say in that.
Who wants to bring in some new
angle or how do they see collective
behavior? Why do we talk about
collective behavior? Why not just
behavior, recognize that behavior is
multiscale or is social,
what's really being communicated with
the collective?
I believe that we chose those levels so
we can make it more simple for our
brains to understand it. Because if we
talk about collective behavior,
actually is the universe behaving and
the particles and everything, right?
So I don't know if that's a little bit
just based on I don't know what's the
word, like, just the material world and
how it physically moves and that's like
deterministic or whatever, right? But I
think us, we chose to have those
limitations so we could understand the
world, but also we should acknowledge
that our limited because we're part of
the system.
I'm having a little trouble on my kind
of understanding, I guess, where the
schism lies between kind of the
Markov blanket and the umwelt
in semiotics of the animals
sensory experience.
Anyone have maybe someone could Daniel,
do you know the difference between that
two? Can you be a little louder?
Thank you, though. Andrew? Anyone have a
thought on that? I'll bring in a
definition of then and then we can see.
But meanwhile, does anyone have a.
Sorry. Sorry, I was just muted on zoom.
Andrew, you're a little quiet, but I'm
going to bring in a definition of umvelt
and then meanwhile, does anyone have a
thought?
I hope I'm not further
diluting Andrew's question,
but I think of collective behavior in
kind of like, I don't know, a football
team or a soccer team and what that
provides the
group who shares
some common ethos and what that does to
the how that regulates their collective
or individual and collective free
energies during a match or
throughout the season, and how that
gives some
charge to some investment.
Because it's my team against yours,
and we have to try and win.
And so without that collective
behavior,
it might be far harder to achieve a
group's goals if they aren't able to
collaborate and share implicitly
and explicitly certain traits,
behaviors, thoughts, feelings, ideals,
ideologies, whatever they might be, and
how that then allows us to compete
in the world.
I see what you're saying. It's brain.
Yes, okay. I see what you're saying.
Especially because we're watching the
World Cup, right? Women's World Cup.
Yeah. So it's very relevant. But I see
that in all the things you've said,
it seems that for you, behavior needs to
have like a goal. And I don't know if
I agree with that. It's either survival
or winning. But maybe for me,
it's just something that happens and
maybe the consequence is surviving, but
it's not the goal to survive or to win
the game. I mean, in the football it is,
right? But in general,
maybe there's no goal to the behavior
collectively,
just the thoughts. It's interesting.
Yeah, a lot of great comments. Well,
the paper of Connor Hines
at all on the collective behavior as
surprise minimization that points the
way towards using the act infontology
these kinds of modeling approaches for
collective behavioral situations and
really just recognizing them as a
certain type of behavioral modeling.
The simplest case might just be a single
closed system,
all part of the composition
that leads to the ability to describe
at very least a lot of different kinds
of systems, just like a linear model can
describe a lot of systems. So then it's
also really interesting a topic that
came up in one of the recent textbook
groups with what's normative about
active inference, because the term of
the process theory, even of active
inference being normative is mentioned
multiple times. And that's definitely a
topic that connects to the social
sciences. One can imagine the kind of
niche normativity or niche regularities
in a broad sense and then the
real minute particulars of how they play
out, which kind of hints at the kind of
descriptive or causal minimum
to start making some anything but toy
specific generative models.
So it's been an interesting theme to
see, even already in Abel's
and Ben's lectures and discussions
this question between description
process of describing which is what
I associated with Professor Gordon's
approach to ant watching how that
descriptive process which is what we can
say that we have for active inference,
just like a linear modeling ecosystem
could say about their linear modeling in
principle, and how to then
articulate the normativities of the
framework, if that concept,
if that separation can even exist from
the behavioral normativities
that include the basis of social
fabric in all different kinds
of communities.
Here's another question. So what is
the role of any technical detail
in the social sciences, whether more on
the statistical connecting with data or
more category theoretic, like just
formal? What's the role of formal
methods in different
kinds of academic or practical
expressions about social systems.
Does it matter at all how
we think about a framework at all?
Well, for formalizing aspects
of a social system, I would say that the
purpose is for communication between
individuals because just we
can't verify that. Well,
formalizing it is just setting a system
on top of what you're observing.
But there is no explicit
guarantee what you're saying encompasses
everything of the phenomena you're
observing. And.
Just. Kind of
going back to Taoism of the
name that can be named is not the true
eternal name. And so it's just a way
of it's a slice of
what we can observe. And maybe
you can make predictions or maybe you
can generate something that acts like
the phenomena you're observing.
It's a way to kind of it's
just a way to kind of approximate our
understanding of some phenomena. And you
have to slice it in a specific way, but
also understanding that it is a slice or
it is a tangent line that you're
approximating as opposed to encompassing
the whole system from verbalizing
it.
I will add maybe it's not the goal but
something that happens out of describing
any system. Like Andrew said, it's like
the goal to modify it or
to corrupt it in some way to gain
control or whatever. If you know the
model, you know how to play the game,
kind of. So you write instructions
and try to see if you can outsmart
someone else. I mean, it sounds kind of
dark, right? But maybe it's one of the
goals too, or something that just
happens out of knowing the rules that
nobody else knows.
I guess when you talk about control,
there is a shade that can be gained
from that specific wording. But control
in terms of control theory or that comes
from electrical engineering and it's
really just what
shapes the behavior or what are the
inputs that drive the behavior. And when
you're talking about control, it's
really just about well, if you change
these inputs, how does that change the
end behavior? And so you can actually
from electrical engineering of control
in some sort of electromechanical
system, but then you can make analogous
statements on control into society
which doesn't necessarily mean the dark
negative control, but maybe there's some
pathological behavior in a society or
even pathological pathological
responses within the brain and it's
like, well, what is driving that? And is
it possible to change
the drivers of that to have something
that is more beneficial
to the system?
Yeah, just to add to what Andrew's
saying, because it matters how
you manipulate a
system or it matters how you affect a
brain. So it cannot be random. I mean,
we've come a long way, for example,
from lobotomy, which had disastrous
effects. And it matters to
a system how you affect it. And so to
know more formally the most effective
way to create a desired effect,
whatever that might be it's essential
that it's not just kind of poking and
prodding that is as
much as that is part of the scientific
method to update that method
in accordance with what you're learning
is important.
No, I think you're both right. It
doesn't have to be dark. But also
something else that Andrew said about
predicting. I think that's one of also
the big goals trying to predict
whether to be prepared it
couldn't be to control right, but if you
can somehow predict how people respond
to this or how a system will behave in
this other scenario you can change
what the input is or prepare for
whatever comes, I guess.
Yeah, a lot of great points.
Some of the commonly held not equally
by everyone, everyone, but some of the
tenets of science being to explain
predict design and control where
explanation and fiction are on
the pathway towards systems designing
and maintenance and other words that
people can add. But that's the pragmatic
utility oriented view which doesn't
have to be an absolutist view but
certainly there are regimes of attention
socially now and seemingly for long long
times where people were wanting to
retain and to constrain the variance
distribution on what we would say
is their generative model. Some norm and
then other times engaging in these
functions. And that instrumentalist
usage of active inference is like we're
going to be able to model it with a
pretty minimum framework that's
commonly used in statistical systems
where some things we observe and some we
don't, and at least we know and how all
the pieces are connected. And then that
is an artifact in model based design as
people develop
that line through time socially,
just like probably has been always the
case for complex projects and scientific
collaboration.
There's a few other interesting pieces
but yeah, please. I'm just
wondering if now that I'm thinking out
loud, isn't that like a problem for
confirmation bias? Right? Like there's a
paper in here. Here because we create
the knowledge and we tell everyone the
knowledge this is the model, this is how
everything behaves and then we update
our knowledge about it and then we look
for everything to just confirm it.
Maybe there's other system that will not
let us be getting knowledge so slowly
because if everybody just agrees on
something we teach it to everyone and we
confirm the model and then we just try
to look for evidence for that model then
we go slowly if there's any better thing
or better model that comes along.
Yeah, a lot to say about that. Like if
we believe that trees exist or that
people exist and then we come to see
them. So there's kind of this sense
where problem confirmation bias which I
think is a great term, a great topic to
bring in with definitely also what's
called like the golden nail syndrome or
something. If all you have is the hammer
then everything is a nail and there's
definitely attention there because it's
like how much of what you can do are you
supposed to do something that you can't
do, but then at least you could do what
you needed to do to get there. So that's
actually within your scope of what you
can do. So it's not that there are
things that you can't do that you can't
do if just from a measurement
perspective. So how
does it look? Or how do we recognize
across systems or how do we have
awareness in situations as limited
individuals who do have all of these
cognitive phenomena, how to make
decisions or sense making or
infrastructure or whatever it is the
socialness the system of interest
of the social sciences make that and
then dot, dot, dot normatively what?
I think there's some protection built
into the problem
of confirmation bias because all
knowledge generation is happening in an
open system. And so there's always going
to be an agent outside of your
own mind and what it's perceiving that
can then challenge or add to
the super, the LK 99
semiconductors that has been all the
rage recently and how other scientists
have now kind of discredited it
quite convincingly. And it's because of
this open they might have had degrees of
confirmation bias that they were egging
each other on, but it's ultimately been
refuted, which is this built
in kind of protection because it's all
operating in an open system.
Fortunately.
Yeah, a lot to say there. Monday Morning
Reviewer twoing how how do we again go
from any given description of a
communicative event like the kind of
specific unfolding of the LK 99
narrative, as yet uncompleted
in the minds of some, which is real
enough to be real socially?
So how do we go from any descriptive
anything about that total observation to
core screening then
how do we come to work
with that interface, with whatever that
is hands that to us?
What is the social behavior? What are
some classic or some
novel social behavioral,
maybe ones that seem pretty obvious due
to recency bias?
I'll just mention one aspect that Andrew
and I have also talked about is the
autopoietic nature of information
systems. Andrew, do you have any
thought on this or about where
autopoiesis comes into,
like, social sciences or these kinds of
models?
Daniel andrew just left a note that he's
back. He just wasn't looking at the
time. Funny stuff. Anyone else have a
thought on that?
Okay, just just to kind of carry forward
then. Basically the ability of social
systems that include written niche
modification, cumulative culture,
their increasing extent
of control as discussed earlier,
that definitely is a bit of an
overloaded or at. Least doubly meant
term in different settings because it
can just simply mean modeling it with
control theory, which is a pretty
limited philosophical statement relative
to any statistical method or control.
Like the kind that people are unhappy
with and the kind that's described in
Thinking Like a State. And a lot of
other works that I know Mahault and
Lorena and Abel are going to be
definitely going into more detail
on. So when societies can model and
introspect or self reflect formally
much better,
and that can happen through anything
from free and open source federated
protocols, there's many limited formats
of self meaning making, but cryptography
definitely allows those explorations,
and that doesn't necessarily mean
computer cryptography. That could also
be like linguistic encoding and all
these other ways of niche sub
differentiation in multiscale systems.
You just do not see a system that
is cookie cutter.
It's very rare in ecosystems.
There are algal blooms and things like
that. So when we really
think about the developmental and the
cognitive and the selective niche,
which is a concept that Axel Constant
and others have differentiated in some
of their ecological active inference,
like, that niche is very embodied,
extended. And cultured, et cetera, et
cetera. It's just like a kind of cool,
direct way to open up to that
challenge of modeling and just
bring some closures
with different accounts or
compatibilities with different accounts.
Just to give one random example. But
maybe it'd be interesting what what
other people think. All the expressions
that people make in social settings can
just simply be their expressions or
modeled as such. That is in
one way implicitly what was always
in play, but now it's
describable and legible and autonomous.
So how do we take this active inference,
collective behavior crossover and
think about what it really means in how
we're going to be thinking differently,
even just this discussion forward or
more locally, our understandings with
collective behavior or with behavior?
Daniel, can you ask the question again?
I didn't actually catch the question.
How do we start to adapt some of these
general comments or
frames that are in some ways
disconnected from descriptions of real
systems? How do we think about that and
what it means now?
Sorry, go ahead. That's okay.
Do you mean on the document in front of
us? These disconnected things in front
of us, they're on the document.
I don't know, whatever you think or
whatever you want to say.
Okay,
yeah, I again,
I hope I'm not fully
understanding the question. I hope I'm
not steering away too much, but I had
a general sense of what I think you were
saying, and I
think it's an enormous problem with the
amount of information sharing.
Just let's just take the
generative models of social
media and all of the platforms that are
available to us, how much information we
are privy to in any given moment.
And I'm kind of forgetting
the question that you asked, but how
do you it's almost as
if there is such a high rate
of information and data flow that it's
really hard to know what to do with all
of it. At least as a
human being. I'm not saying for
machines, but as
a psychologist. I'm certainly interested
in how humans are able
to tolerate and respond to the
amount and rate of information that's
out there.
This is not the first time this happens,
right? Like we went from talking to
writing information, then everyone wrote
their information and then we have books
and then we have libraries and that's
all available. And again, we have
access, if you can read right, to all
the information in the world. So we
adapted to, I don't know,
to get careers so we could specify in
which type of information you are going
to know more. So maybe we need some sort
of new career type, I don't know, more
specification with more information.
But is the rate of information
flow and increase? Is it not
exponential? I don't
know. It's a crazy amount and our brains
cannot do anything about it. So we have
to do multidisciplinary things and work
together with others if we want to make
something. But yeah,
I don't know, maybe we will die of
excess of information.
How do people feel like active inference
brings something to the discussion
relative to how they want to
work towards ants?
Yeah, well, isn't that the provocative
question too? But like any system,
that's the question. Everyone is going
to have their own memes and themes and
systems that they have spent time with
and did field work with and all this
other particularity because a system
that doesn't have particularity is just
not going to be hosting a broad
enough niche for phenotypic diversity.
It's just riding on the edge of a razor
instead of more like a fabric that
continues to unfold. I think there's
a lot of work to do with the social
sciences and active inference just from
what I was reading, trying to find
things for this discussion
and just I personally wondered what is
meaningful or interesting or useful,
what's epistemic and pragmatic value for
different audiences? How does it go from
kind of bringing citations that were not
linked together in
some more theoretical or more generative
model oriented work in active inference
like epistemic foraging or
the infra ants model or any
other kind of specific model? What do
these different kinds of scientific
artifacts do for
who?
I guess I'm still learning very crudely
ploddling along here, Daniel, to try and
answer that because I've quickly
realized that the field is so multi
nodal. It has so much the
free energy principle, the Bayesian
brain, even just to psychology,
has so much applicability. And everyone
I meet at these discussions is coming at
it from a different angle. And it can
be a bit confusing to hear how other
people are applying it,
how other people are making use
of it in all manner of ways.
And so I'm still learning how to apply
to kind of ring fence, the free energy
principle and connect it to
psychological processes including
collective behavior because there's a
lot of psychopathology in group think in
collective behavior, but I'm also very
interested in its application at the
interface of what happens between
a therapist and a patient. I'm often,
unlike other professions,
who are just by nature of the scientific
method, are able to extract a lot
more data to work with, to analyze,
to,
you know, in a in a that's very hard
to do. I feel very limited other than
just making kind of theoretical leaps
and inferences about how to apply the
free energy principle to psychology.
I can't have a session with my brain
hooked up to an fMRI machine to get data
and to see when a patient says
boo or bar, that's a spike on the spike
trains, which represents surprisal,
and we can then solve for that in some
way. I don't have access to that sort of
data flow, so it feels limited, but I'm
still learning how to apply it and
trying to collaborate with colleagues on
the influence group.
What are people wondering about
collective behavior, even if we're
totally, of course, not going to address
it, but just what are the kinds of
things that people what
makes you look up collective behavior
instead of just behavior or individual
behavioral?
For me, it's about safety and need to
belong.
For me,
I think that it depends where you come
from and the country you are,
but there are places that are more
collective, and there are places that
are more individualistic. And I think
mostly non Western countries have a lot
of collective behavior and knowledge and
spirits already. Right. That they
already knew these things that we think
are new for us. Right. How the
collective thing works, for example, I
don't know. You don't make a decision
for yourself. You make a decision for
the group. Like marrying. You marry
because you want an addition. You want
to interact with someone or other group.
And that's something that affects the
collective, not just you. So arranged
marriage makes sense. Something like
that. Right. So for me, making that
distinction about individual collective
comes from understanding that, I don't
know, there are other places that are
already ahead in what collective means
in terms of human beings and how to
interact. And the Western world, we have
all this individualistic thing, which is
very interesting because why do we have
the same species? And then we have very
different approaches of how to
understand ourselves in terms of what an
individual is and why it matters.
Yes. There's so much loaded on different
understandings among people, including
even the essence of the social, which is
who are people and what is the
obligation and how do we view that
relationship? That's a very
deep area. Again, the part that just
kept returning to me in the lecture and
when I was trying to think about how to
even reflect part of this very large
area is like, what is the adjective
doing and what's the reference
point by which this is being said in.
The speech act like people often will
dismiss I don't mean to straw people but
dismiss collective behavior by saying
well, we are explaining individual
behavior. What are you explaining beyond
the nest mates in the colony and then
the exterior, that is it.
And so that can feel like looking at
the same thing from two different sides.
And there are different methods, like
some methods blur over individuals a lot
more like statistical methods that might
correspond to demographics and then on
the other hand, like more agent based
models.
But how much variability and what
shared variability in what
general synchronies amongst
different quantum reference frames? All
these nested at least possibilities
that are grounded in wanting to explore
mathematical and scientific
possibilities as the literature of
linear regression is full of so many
incredible extensions and similar.
And then I think
what the course is even beginning to
try to express and what I understand in
the works of the other teachers and a
lot of your backgrounds and everything
like that is where
is that moment
where it is not only science,
because science is not simply the
social. So science as an activity and
then as there's a diffusion away from
science,
or at least that relationship between
social and science is right there in the
title. Maybe that's kind of like a
science major's take but it is itself in
a way presenting
a dilemma with what science means
there and then that's the frame game
who's doing social science? Who's doing
not social science? And that's
where in the culture
I'm sitting in, in the technical side of
that it is related to statistics and
formality. It's the Xkcd comic
and the way that formalisms and details
are taken as under
some regimes of attention basically
definitive. And yet there's like
a yearning and a counterbalancing that's
expressed also in many ways.
And science maybe some people feel like
certain social scientific methods that's
like not far enough in this dimension
and then the others feel like they're
too far in this direction. But it's like
just like that academic field, let alone
any other community of diverse agents.
Of course there's going to be
distributions of perspectives
at different times and
rate. Of uptake by those different
perspectives.
Daniel, do you think these
first principles would
be able to explain why an
ant colony exists? I know that was
your kind of area of interest of study.
Why an ant colony exists in
the way that it does as a operating as a
collective and why another
animal is able to survive and
achieve its. Goals.
As an individual only relying on the
environment and its actions and
sensations to get its needs met and to
no doubt minimize its free energy. But
could first principles explain why
the one has to survive as a group and
the other has to survive or is able to
survive under different conditions?
Yeah, that's a super interesting
question. It's very core to this
individuation and multiscale
individuation concept. Like is
the nest mate the individual and then
the colony? Is the social? Because then
for sure it's super collaborative. Or is
the colony the organism? And nest mates
are tissues and then are they social
across colony boundaries? Not where I
was in Arizona, but they're often
friendly across different species and
they avoided conflict more often than
not. And then why does it
even matter what's happening on this
plot of lands in
this area? From like a biomimicry
perspective, we might learn new
algorithms. It's a sandbox for learning
new techniques and observation, all
these other richnesses. So it's to say
though, what comes away from that
science that makes it social science.
And I think there's a lot of
disciplinary ways of understanding that,
which I'm definitely not expert in in
the professional fields like counseling,
but probably in all the different
humanities and histories and all these
other fields, all these different maps,
the kind of social the
epistemic organizing question and then
the social organizing question and
the way that technology is also in that
tangle. And yeah, someone pointed out
like, this is not a new problem,
but then it's like, well, what parts are
new? And then what's our model by which
we're saying that it's like new or too
individualist or too collective? On what
scale? What if they're like, really
collectivist at this scale, but not at
this scale or another? An example of an
ambiguous or at least like polysimus
phenotype of colonies is in some
colonies there's partial reproductive
activation of non reproductive
nest mates. And that has often been
modeled from a position of zero is the
law and how are they cheating above
this? But it's also been approached from
a colony level strategic bet hedging.
So without super deep knowledge of
really some of the specifics of the
regularities that that colony algorithm
had to persist for so long and
to have gotten swept off the table if it
was even that's a very integrated
problem. So it helps you approach
collective systems and learn about them.
But it's like there's a lot to say about
humidity loss in foraging and humidity
loss isn't even the whole picture.
And human foraging is a lot more
sophisticated from just like a
perception, cognition, influence,
perspective. So those
are just some ant related thoughts, but
it just centers a lot of discussions
that really matter. And I think the
really interesting piece is not always
in the way that they're thought
to by some.
Yeah, and it's very hard to get
any kind of cross pollination or to see
cross pollination studying
one agent. It's quite, at least to my
mind, very difficult to kind of
generalize things across different
agents. It starts getting a bit tricky
to infer one collective's
how and why and how they survive and how
another agent does. It's tricky. So I'm
almost just going to an agent. Human
beings, as hard as they are to study and
just try and run with it as far as
possible.
Otherwise it's just information
overload.
Body is a complex place too,
and digital technology,
virtuality, these are such
richly developed topics in the social
sciences. I only know the tiniest amount
from but I think that through
participation and inclusion in
collaboration and in conversations and
everything, there's going to be a lot of
interesting connections and paths
and it's
being approached seemingly multiple
layers. The two layers that just we can
focus most narrowly on is like within
the realm of science, what is science?
Which is kind of like playing this other
role with inertia in some people's minds
and in systems, what is science? Who
gets to decide what social science is?
I don't know. I'm not in social science
but it's system of interest to society
and certainly I'm a part of that. So
it's like what is good technically,
what is social scientific and
then what is that social scientific?
How is that going to interface into the
metaphysical questions and the normative
ethical and the decision
making with trade offs and the real
reflexive complex decisions that matter?
Also while recognizing this increasingly
nuanced way of thinking about different
social intelligences,
what's any other random thought or
curiosity about collective behavior?
One point that I would have added in to
the lecture was just that in distributed
systems, whether as modeled or as such,
all behavior is arising from
interactions local to individuals. Even
if it's sent through some wireless
mechanism, it's like all about the local
interactions. And so that is
an arising type process that gives the
modeler like one hands off layer at
least, if not much more. Another nice
feature about them, they are
in a way waiting to be composed because
they intrinsically contain at least two
layers of consideration. Now whether
there's kind of like a forcing function
of one layer and just sort of dangling a
bottom layer or whether there's a lot of
what we would call emergence or
discussive in that way that more
arising function can be modeled. But in
either way then you can kind of wrap
that two layer system and then compose
them. So that's like what enables in
certain situations like parallelization
or at least that's obviously a big area.
But that's what allows multi agent
simulation frameworks to do well
on certain very challenging sense making
and action selection problems, not by
guarantee or default because any given
slicing and dicing of any given
prompting of information may not help
you adapt but
there are paths that do and don't help,
persist or not. And that's this kind of
persistence starting place that we
began with. Sasha.
Yeah, I really resonate with what you
mentioned about the local interactions
that even if
information is transmitted over long
distances then the agents behave
in a way that is locally relevant and
integrates that information. And it
actually makes me think a lot about the
psychology therapy angle that
while you try to get information about
the person's sort of local environment
and behavior or perhaps
demographics and age, that their
informational environment, like a wealth
of what kind of information they
consume, might also be really telling
about their psychological
and behavior interactions
or pathologies.
And then to bring it kind of full circle
back to that the researcher
is part of the ecosystem that they are
studying.
Yeah, I think it's just such
a difference in perspective to see that
as like a positive and a gift that the
way that you would design and run an
experiment today is not the way that you
would do it two years from now with more
experience. And so that is a
benefit and like a bonus in the system
and not like a negative perspective of
bias that it's detracting from some
underlying truth or reality.
So, just a few thoughts.
Very interesting. Anyone want to add
something?
I think we didn't fully resolve this
early question about the umvelt term
from ethology behavioral research
observation science using the
term to describe the world as it is
experienced by a particular organism. I
think a few different pieces and there's
a lot of discussion in discourse. This
is just to give it like a super short
overview the world we might connect to
world modeling and there's a lot of
interesting work in all kinds of
different pros focus on qualitative
systems as well as some artificial or
synthetic intelligence. World modeling
as it is experienced is one of the
sticky and deep ones because this is the
area of phenomenology. And so this is
like a kind of semi eternal discussion
point. So whether active inference
delivers on world modeling is kind of
empirical and just plain whereas as it
is experienced is going to be a
philosophical question and then by a
particular organism that specificity we
get by actually making the generative
model even if we're just speculating
about it. It's like talking about
experience without an experiencer would
be like talking about some agent's
behavior without reference to its niche.
And then where there is like that
complex negotiation I think the
humanities and a lot of the social
sciences have identified a lot of the
structural top down and also the
personal bottom up motifs
of things being blurred
and made complex. And so
I think part of the social and the
scientific as coming only from the
scientific side is like to
meet in the third space and or at
least make it work to have a mutual
compromise where it's like certain
social oriented claims based upon this
scientific measure that is going to be a
judgment call. But understanding that
conversation, where is it a mutual
compromise? In what dimensions? Not
simply along the kind of rigor,
accessibility or implications axis.
There's just very many things in play in
these Iterated relationships in
ecosystems,
having a researcher as part of the
ecosystem. Well, here's the forager
question. We see the nest mate on the
ground, it's a forager. But then we step
back, it's like, okay, well, it's
foraging. And then that's the allocation
of the forager. Then its foraging is
still part of this sense making, this
generative sense making with process
understanding even of a trace,
which is something that Bruno Latour and
others have explored with, like
following a trace in a social setting
and using that to trace networks.
So in our digital ecosystems, though,
our information ecosystems is not
research happening. And so what
does that really mean? And then what are
those social normativities? There is
going to be like a meeting or a handoff
with where that really is happening,
or maybe it's a knocking on the door
that's ignored.
Or it could be whatever metaphor
in that setting it actually is.
There's no general metaphor because
that'd be like, oh, what's the general
metaphor on this experiment? Which
experiment? Just the general action that
we plan to take. Oh,
hard to say.
It okay. Well, in our last sections,
I guess if anybody types a question live
chat we'll look at, otherwise, what are
any other thoughts? Or like,
what what can we learn
more about about collective behavior?
Or what will it mean for our sense
making, decision making, if we
understand collective behavior better?
What else are people excited about for
the rest of the course?
Like, based upon the sections that we've
done so far and
how we can even start to approach
this in an acknowledged, limited,
finite way?
Yeah. Sasha than anyone else.
I just added a question to the very
bottom of the notes, and it makes me
think about how, working on this
document collaboratively throughout the
last hour, we're able to kind
of leave a stigmagic trace of things
we've discussed. And what sort of traits
or practices should individual humans
I guess I should specify humans. Should
we embody in order to improve cohesion
in collective behavior? It makes me
think of certain psychology traits
or descriptions of, like, openness or
conscientiousness.
What will make individual humans
better participants in collective
behavior?
Yeah, I think to add to that,
to just emphasize the importance,
again, only with human agents,
specifically, who have the capacity to
think and reflect, and the only ones
that have those really advanced
capabilities that we know of as yet,
but to really kind of leverage in
order to make the collective better.
There's a responsibility of the
individual, despite being part of
a collective on many different fronts,
to be able to leverage and utilize their
own internal states and
what they have learned, and to be able
to think, to retain
the individual's mind and think about
the collective, I think is so important
if the collective is to become
healthier. Sasha, to your point, and to
improve. Its.
To become more conscientious and become
more responsible or whatever that might
be.
So to always try and maintain a thinking
self is crucial.
You can very easily be usurped into the
collective as is.
If you just go on any social media
platform, you will see individuals
rarely thinking for themselves
and seemingly kind of just fueling each
other. And that causes massive problems.
So an individual mind strikes me as
being just the most important thing in
the future going forward.
It yeah. This dialectic with
individuation and collectivization as
these ongoing negotiated compromise
that can be also viewed many ways.
However, they are cognitive
science coming into play.
Maybe historical processes or
philosophies were used
in many settings for even
approaching these kinds of social
questions. And now with computer science
and technology, it even is a
discussion more about the capacities of
measurement and action. Not that those
are new in and of themselves, but
thinking like a state, like the
development of the apparatus, the
development of the social systems that
can be run on open source hardware,
open source software, things like that.
I don't know if something's generalized
across all such groups,
but understanding
what environments, at least initially
things are beginning at is
just a realist starting point.
Probably no guarantee since most things,
all things are swept off the table in
their specifics anyway.
And how to deal with that kind of like
skin on the line type
of decision making is very interesting
how it's pursued in the sciences because
often many runs are presented or that
kind of catastrophic failure mode of
models is not considered. It's just like
part of the training, starting naive so
just the way that different social
considerations are
converged upon. It's not like reduced to
one feature of the social because the
social is such an open space.
As a scientist, always impressed by how
that writing could kind of open up the
situations which are, like, mundane,
but also, of course, very deep and
meaningful. Also, though,
mundane.
Any other thoughts or
otherwise on collective behavior or on
the social sciences course or anything?
Otherwise people can have any last words
if they want.
Yeah. Awesome. Thank you all for
participating. David, want to add
anything? Excellent.
Yeah. Well, I look forward to more
questions being asked on the course
website. And everybody's engagement with
the course is very much appreciated. So
keep up the collective. Thanks for
multiscale learning, and it's a fun
course. Really happy that we could have
done the session and very happy to have
concluded the session.
All right, thank you. Bye bye. Bern